have you ever told the story about uh
new orleans and and uh getting hit in
the head with a bike lock
like a d-shaped bike line i don't know
i don't know if i doesn't remember i
remember oh no i clearly remember yeah
like no it was just some shady
characters there was a guy like so we
got to the hotel bar we we were in new
orleans oh yeah this is right after
hurricane fresh after well katrina was
august we're there in february right
right and so
i mean dude
we were staying right on the french
quarter it was dead at night like there
was only a few places open and because
like they were
like it was so devastated by katrina
still that there was like more of a
crime element than there had been
previously as i understand it and
because of that we had armed security
with us
like we actually had security guards
like you know with us at night and so
this guy
they weren't with us me that night but
they were great we left them like at
some point the security guard was there
yeah he was there when we first saw this
guy so we were at the hotel bar and this
guy's like oh so you're rich by me
because you're rich buy me a drink i'm
like [ __ ] that noxo says i did i got you
a white russian but i might have come
did it yeah and then i don't remember
that
yeah i remember you said that a word for
it i got you a white russian but i might
have [ __ ] in it and i go up to this
dude and [ __ ] straight shove him
across the the lobby like into the arms
of the security guy right or you know
like every time i ever had security it
just got me into trouble make sure that
like it's like whenever we bring an
ambulance on set well if we're paying
for that ambulance we're going to use
that goddamn envelope
so i shoved this i shoved this guy into
the security he grabs him and just leads
him out of the hotel but then that was
like oh well now now we've made a thing
with these guys right so they [ __ ]
see you later on in the night well bam
bam flies in late that night and so we
get there and uh
it was i don't know it was late like
three o'clock in the morning two o'clock
in the morning even the teddy bear and
the guy uh you know we're at some bar or
like just random bar and uh and this guy
starts [ __ ] with bam and bam wasn't
there earlier so he didn't i'm like oh
[ __ ] that's that [ __ ] guy again
and
we're just drinking trying to calm it
down like his buddy comes and tries to
calm and make it cool
and i was i appreciated that
and then i look and [ __ ] bam and that
dude are fighting out outside i'm like
oh [ __ ] so i run out of fighting like
really fast like yeah like bam's got his
finger in his mouth damn's got the
dude's finger in it bam's mouth biting
him and
so i'm like oh [ __ ] so i run out and as
soon as i run out right bam's biting the
finger bam's biting the guy who
asked you to buy him a drinks finger
it's all your fault and uh and i run out
to break up the fight and right when i
run out i get hit over the head with a
you know like a kryptonite style bike
lock yeah
and and uh the guy behind me who was
working on our crew got hit over the he
got his ear whacked and his back he got
two he got hit twice this guy was
swinging this thing and it was the guy
who tried to make it cool it was the
buddy
he was swung the [ __ ] bike log and i
didn't even think i got hit and it felt
like someone was pouring coffee over my
head it felt like hot water was it was
just blood just running down my [ __ ]
absolute blood bath yeah and then you go
to the hospital you ask the doctor can
you do your own stitches i just wanted a
cool scar like i was never hurt it was
like it was so weird that i would push
on it and i was drunk but i wasn't that
way like i was aware right i was like
[ __ ] why doesn't this hurt this is weird
there's a gash you know big old [ __ ]
gash that was gushing blood but but i
talked to the doctor i'm like listen i'm
i'm artistic
and i think i could do this can you just
supervise me and let me do this artistic
not autism
artistic i'm creative like i'm i'm
talented at [ __ ] like i can i can do it
like i think i could do my own stitches
because it didn't hurt yeah i could
maybe shoot some novocaine in there just
make sure but like and she was not
having not this this we had it took us
forever to find a hospital like right
three of the hospitals were closed derek
had to get out and come find me and get
me to the hospital and so it's derrick
and shawna and me
and
and i'm just like all right listen you
won't let me do it i get it
you're telling me it's a you think it's
gonna be ten stitches but can you just
do it in five do it in five
i want something to shuffle you can't
even [ __ ] see it like there's nothing
there she did such a nice job and she
had so little patience do it in 5.
i'm like i want a scar like i mean don't
get it like do a shitty job just make it
work like i don't care i don't want to
get infected but like do not make it
nice yeah dude thanks for watching that
clip and if you live in america there's
a good chance that this big badass tour
bus is coming to your town with my
bucket list tour what is it well it's an
x-rated show
full of all the stuff that i would have
never have been allowed to do for
jackass and a lot of it is flagrantly
illegal so it's adults only and if you
live in any of these states then you
better go to stevo.com and check out my
tour schedule hurry up and get your
tickets too because it's selling out
everywhere
yeah dude
[Music]